thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies we're made of matter which
means we experience time
but what if we weren't made of matter
what if we were made of something
timeless like
light instead what would the universe be
like for us
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
okay so stuff in the universe generally
falls into two major
categories matter and light
what separates them is the rest mass
matter has it
light doesn't but categorizing things by
their mass can be
problematic because mass is not a
fundamental property
it's an emergent property it appears
out of the interactions between
particles out of the ensemble
seriously consider something extreme
like a black hole
you've probably heard of black holes
eating entire stars
but they don't just eat matter they also
eat light
light is massless but if a black hole
eats some
it'll still grow the light has become
massive
just because it's trapped we call it
confinement
mass emerges from that confinement
for that matter you don't even need the
black hole to begin with
if you get enough light in one place
it'll become a black hole all by itself
it's called a kugelblitz a ball of light
a massless ball made entirely of
massless things
and a similar thing actually happens
inside your body almost
all of your mass comes from the protons
and neutrons at the center of your atoms
about 99 of that mass is from massless
gluons
just because they're confined to a space
about one femtometer wide
my point is you're already made of
massless particles
they're called gluons making you out of
massless photons instead
wouldn't make much difference if they're
confined the collection will still have
mass
which means you'll still experience time
the same way
yeah but what if those millions of
photons aren't confined
then you're not a single object okay
then what if i'm made of a single photon
i see you're not gonna let this go fine
i have no idea how a single photon could
give rise to the complexity of conscious
thought
but i guess we're gonna let that go for
a few minutes and see what happens
how does a single photon freely moving
through space
experience the universe being a photon
you can travel at the speed of light and
that's not something our current selves
have a lot of experience with
humans spend a lot of time sitting still
but we do move around sometimes
we walk at about three miles per hour
and run it maybe eight miles per hour
in a car you might be moving anywhere
between 30 and 70 miles per hour
in a plane you could easily be going
over 500 miles per hour
the fastest any human has ever gone is
about 24
800 miles per hour but that's all
peanuts compared to light
light travels at 671
million miles per hour light goes so
fast
that no human could ever catch up fast
fast
for this to really sink in we need to
consider the concept of momentum
if you're not moving at all your
momentum is zero
the faster you move the bigger your
momentum gets
it's a nice simple linear relationship
but like with most linear relationships
this one has its limits
it only works well for slow speeds this
range
is where the error is less than one
percent the fastest humans have ever
gone
is only point zero zero four percent the
speed of light
which is well within that range in the
realm of human experience
that linear relationship is fine but if
you're traveling anywhere near the speed
of light
the error grows exponentially if a human
traveled at exactly the speed of light
they'd have infinite momentum which is
completely ridiculous
then how can light go that fast by not
having mass
remember all that mass talk at the
beginning of the video yeah
it wasn't just filler according to the
standard model
a photon has zero rest mass
to understand why that matters we need
to look a little closer at that momentum
the equation for momentum from special
relativity has speed in it twice
one on the top of the fraction and one
on the bottom
we have to watch both as a human
approaches the speed of light
the bottom of the fraction approaches
zero as a result
the momentum approaches infinity but
that's actually only true
if the top of the fraction is a normal
number in our case
the mass of a human times the speed of
light
massless particles like photons found a
loophole to this problem
the indeterminate form that's when some
combination of zero
and infinity can unexpectedly give you a
finite non-zero number
the standard indeterminate forms are
zero over zero
infinity over infinity zero times
infinity
infinity minus infinity zero to the zero
power
and infinity to the zero power that
first one
is the loophole photons use it might be
okay to have a zero on the bottom of a
fraction
as long as you also have one on top
photons do that by having zero mass
that's what allows them to travel at the
speed of light and not have infinite
momentum
a zero mass gives us zero over zero
an indeterminate form and the result is
a finite
non-zero momentum kinda cool huh
anyway some weird stuff happens as you
approach the speed of light
length contracts time dilates it's crazy
counterintuitive
if you're unfamiliar with it and not
only that those effects
are relative as we watch this
accelerating rocket shrink in length
and see its clock slow down any
passenger on that rocket will see the
same thing
happen to the rest of the universe the
entire universe will contract
along the direction of motion and it
will take more time for things to happen
in that universe
but remember the rocket can never
actually reach the speed of light
so time will never actually stop the
clock
will always be ticking forward just
extremely slowly
but a photon can go at exactly the speed
of light i mean
it can't go any other speed plugging any
other speed
into this equation would make a photon's
momentum zero
which means it wouldn't exist photons
have to travel at the speed of light or
they don't exist
and that has relativistic consequences
if you take this effect to the extreme
limit
the universe will flatten to zero
thickness and time
will dilate to infinity for a freely
traveling photon
the moment it's created is the moment
it's destroyed
and those events happen at the same
place which is the only place
nothing would be happening in the
surrounding universe because the
surrounding universe wouldn't exist
so what would it be like to be made of
photons well if you're a collection of
photons
everything is basically the same the
confinement of those photons would still
give you mass
in exactly the same way your gluons
already do
you would still experience time but if
somehow you are a single photon freely
moving through the universe
that's when things get weird as massive
things approach the speed of light
the rest of the universe shrinks and
slows
as a single photon you would take this
effect to its inevitable limit
and the surrounding universe would cease
to exist
photons don't experience anything
photons
are timeless so would you want to be
made of light
please share in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like matthew o'connor
who's been supporting us at the asylum
counselor level for over a year
wow that's a lot of support don't forget
to subscribe if you'd like to keep up
with us
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy
do you want to learn something new well
brilliant is the place for you
it's a website and app that makes
learning accessible and fun
brilliance courses are laid out like a
story and broken into pieces
so you can tackle them one bit at a time
and there are over 60 of them
so there's something for everyone
brilliant calculus fundamentals course
begins with a quiz on indeterminate
forms and is part of one of their
learning paths
a collection of courses that help guide
you in a particular direction
you might also like their special
relativity course which has quizzes on
photons tachyons and causality
brilliance approach is based on problem
solving and active learning
it's about seeing concepts visually
interacting with them
and then answering questions that make
you think if this sounds like a service
you'd like to use
go to brilliant.org science asylum today
the first 200 subscribers we'll get 20
off an annual subscription
[Music]
wait a minute how can galaxies travel
faster than light
well they're not really traveling that
fast in their local space
it's just an illusion created by the
expansion i'll elaborate in a future
video
anyway thanks for watching